it's something I gotta find something
all right you gotta find a struggle it's
very important to have a struggle gotta
have something you got accomplished
because you complain I've already oh we
competitive it there's a little bit of
that what's going on man you how do I
turn the hip on over there which one is
it Jamie check check check
oh he's in my ears we're live what's our
UI it's crazy how we look at each other
when walking I know it's crazy let me
embrace lean into you huh it's been a
long time
hey man what's up now where do you go
now I don't know just try to stay alive
keep moving no you're doing it I mean
whose ass are you gonna work one day one
day stand up you've called out somebody
you called out a [ __ ] we get in
the crate that was crazy when we was
doing stand-up like it was like it was
like gunslingers what happened was there
nothing you called him out there well
that was a bad situation we had a he was
stealing everybody
am i bringing up the wrong [ __ ] no no
it's okay Oh cuz I was getting try to be
nice because the terrain we was just
talking about off of Mike about how how
would we would have been in jail yeah
had there been social media we'd have
life double life I'll be looking at you
of myself in you had to kill colors well
we were talking about everybody that
like came up in the 60s or 70s the 80s
the 90s everyone before social media the
wild lives they lead you can't do that
anymore you can't do it and what this
comes as you came for all y'all just you
know tune in we were talking about like
you know Chris Brown I'll see Chris
Brown he'll come on my house and he'll
he'll he'll just sit there and go like
what the [ __ ] you know and I said listen
you're just too talented for one cat's
like him and Justin Bieber who've been
who've been blessed with extra they look
good they can fight they they're
athletic and they sing like a damn stick
a dance
first time I met Chris Brown this is
crazy I'm throwing a party in Miami and
it's me and Colin Farrell Eddie Murphy
you know anywhere if he was still in it
this years back
like to 2005 me I think yeah 2005 and so
I'm hosting a party when in Miami the
crowds going crazy with in the down like
not in the VIP it's some kids dancing
I think dance you know this year and so
my DJ DJ our egos y'all man that's a new
kid Chris Brown you he bout to be the
next one I said yeah but he think he can
damn cuz you know I'm not dad I'll go
[ __ ] him up this young know who I am
I'll come down and [ __ ] him up and it
was like okay so I'll go down there now
you know it's sort of my time and so
everybody's following me I'm about to go
battle whoever this kid is so I said
yeah bro you think you could dance on I
did like some kind of [ __ ] listen to
me we're all we're all jammed together
right he doesn't do a move you know what
he does he does a backflip but the way
he did the backflip and he's 6 2 he's
standing in the middle of the crowd he
jumped over the crowd did the backflip
up here and came straight down and said
what's up I said mom I got my leave you
the [ __ ] Avenger [ __ ] and I just said
that do when he get on and then you know
he gets on but then social media catches
on and then it's just hard it's hard
it's it's hard to live when you live
when your social media not telling all
the time you have this social media sort
of makes you color inside the lines
yeah or try to I try to yeah or like
this it makes you took your artistry and
sometimes does that mean tuck you crazy
and tuck you crazy and you tuck your
artistry in like I didn't know what a
mean wasn't you know I'm you know you
know [ __ ] I'm gonna [ __ ] I was just
catching on to MySpace and [ __ ] shifted
so my daughter sends me a picture
Rhianna right going to the Met Ball and
by the time I got the picture whatever
happened
the picture was Rihanna and and in his
yellow dress and I hit my daughter I
said I love the dress is amazing I don't
understand the pizza that's in it but me
you know maybe that's a you know she's
given a nod to Italy or maybe she got
the dress forever
she's like no dad that's a meme I said
way that's a meme so what do you mean
she says no there's actually not a pizza
in the dress somebody crafted or fixed
it there they made it look like it's
pizza because oh because it's trailing
behind her and so me I'm thinking well
what the [ __ ] does it mean this is know
I said so this girl worked her whole
[ __ ] night to get this dress to go to
the Met Ball which is you're supposed to
be you know out the box and somebody
puts a pizza on it and that's all you
see is a pizza I said how do you compete
with that how could you be Michael
Jordan and kids run up do you say like
the best thing on the internet it's one
of the best things about the it is
people being able to make funny it's the
best thing but watch this so it wants
his sticks that's what I'm saying
Michael warning to somebody under the
age of 18 heat a cry baby face you know
fans do a mean cry right we go yeah yeah
well we were talking about Jon Jones you
had how John Jones fighting this weekend
oh yeah John Jones is a wild
[ __ ] and that's why he's the
greatest light heavyweight of all time
because he's so pits part of it you have
to have it we talked about going go be
with Mike Tyson Mike Tyson back in the
day you couldn't that's why when people
say like why does Mike Tyson first of
all he's a fighter he's not a tennis
player but Mike was a WoW boy and to
hang out with him
you could understand like he was the
biggest person on the planet and he had
the demons you know I'm saying and but
he's fun to look at because you see him
in a club and he sees he sees some girls
eww like cars like BMWs and crazy he'd
take the girls out and go get a BMW I
mean he was that crazy come on come on
look at the beer and we open up the BMW
dealership but he was wild but I say
just like how we saying off it you can't
have that type of talent in that area
and not have this John John Jones can't
you can't you can't drink milk and and
almost kill somebody you can yeah
there's got to be something about you
that's out of control in the impulsive
wild dangerous and that's what makes him
so great everybody even talked about you
look at the people on your wall you look
at Hendrix you look at Elvis they have
to have something because that's God
[ __ ] with ya God's gonna give you
something incredible but he's also gonna
give you something to anchor that
because I believe this is what I believe
in and you tell me if you believe I
believe in the yin and the yang of
everything meaning like when there's
absolute light there has to be absolute
darkness to balance it out and that's
with everything that we do it's sort of
like we're not gonna get away with
anything by anything that happens to you
in life you have to pay for it like it's
like the grocery store okay I got the
career boom gotta pay for that okay I
got the money okay I gotta pay then here
come the family oh yeah I need that
money yeah you you you [ __ ] I'm going
I'm going
I'm a recent released a story about you
so it's all of these different things
that you got to pay for and that's why
you see these guys like that cuz you
know like I said talking to Justin
Bieber you know where everything that
said some of this [ __ ] is supposed to
happen to you it has to you can't
otherwise the think of the success that
kids had at 20 years old it's impossible
I was just reading some [ __ ] about him
canceling his tour yeah cuz he just had
too much work
I mean he's just going crazy I guess but
he's made 93 million dollars this year
yeah like Jesus Christ yeah
I'm gonna take that 90 million I'm gonna
go do a million but we can't be in his
mind and we can't see how it is he grew
up that way and grew up that way never
had a normal life and you don't expect
like I like I always tell kids who want
to be in this business - please wait
like even when my kids - just wait wait
till you like wait you're gonna
understand like I was able to be grown
and have some grown [ __ ] happened to me
and just regular life should happen so
that when this happened I still have a
point of reference to get back to
because you know like I know you've
interviewed everybody this business
affects you in such a way where you'll
see one person one day I won't say the
comedian's name but I remember a
comedian back in the day did like half
of an HBO whatever and then the next
week I saw him he had 12 bodyguards and
they were pushing me back just got crazy
got crazy crazy crazy and I see I won't
say the names but they've been a couple
of guys I never get this one to hit and
I went up to try to say something to him
it and for some reason he had a white
suit on white suit on and these big
shades and I went to talk to him and he
said not right now man I'm rich just let
me be rich and famous right now I don't
want to hear your pitch about pitching
summits man you think you could get away
and as he said it I had to sort of like
okay but that's you know that's what
happens but you gotta be careful that
tide goes in and it goes out and people
come up and they remember they remember
and they remember when you [ __ ] with
them and we see and we've seen them
we've seen them but but being a comedian
we get we get a chance to sit in a
different seat because we sort of are
our jobs or observational you know and
we still all have our own demons but
it's it's just different
you also get humbled as a comedian yeah
you got to get those jokes you're
performing in front of a live audience
it's all alive you got to work and it
doesn't work
back to drawing boys got assessed actors
don't get a lot of that that's one of
the reasons why they're kind of shaky
yeah more shaky yeah right they don't
get a lot of like that testing it live
in front of people that humility only
comes with that you don't and it's and
it's tough I was talking to actor
another actor it stuck I see I'm a comic
who became an actor so I'm cheating do
this and I know I'm a being st. Louis
tomorrow you know that's a joke so I can
you know I gotta get my thing off but
just actors it's tough when you figure
out a way to balance three careers you
sing too I mean you could do anything
you're a weird guy in that way you got a
lot of weird talent yourself is he
talking about Justin Bieber and yeah
Chris Brown you've got some weird
ability to shift to its I not only had
but I've been fortunate in the fact that
nothing's I've opened up like you know
back in the day like you could only do
one thing one thing I would never forget
Keenen Ivory Wayans told me say yo
what's with the singing [ __ ] yo you
warned them of it I can't see you try to
sing can you see them no this is real in
gurbin Oh Jaime stop you too funny in
the face - funny I see Wanda singing to
me you finally that's porn ba stop so I
was like [ __ ] maybe I'll never sing you
don't so I was doing of course to stand
up you know doing the wireless [ __ ] and
then it wasn't until literally I was
throwing these parties in my crib and I
would always throw parties for like
musical guys you know so I threw a party
for puff puff comes and big party it's
like mm puff is there and it's all about
him and I'll never get he got mad at me
a little bit because I would follow him
and I I would actually follow him with
it with a camera because I thought that
at that time puff was the biggest guy in
the world you know you couldn't get in
his party so the way I were getting this
party is I show up with a camera like
you're puff you need document document -
[ __ ] what's up Playboy I said yeah let
me get there ain't nobody getting this
tonight and it wasn't back in the day
with the you know with the camera phone
I had the big [ __ ] cannon that you
put on your shoulder in the light and
[ __ ] I said let me change the battery
let me get all this [ __ ] right so at one
point I told him we were actually in
Philly
he was throwing a party he said you'll
Playboy this party's a million and a
half dollars I said like what I'm saying
he said it'd cost a million and a half
dollars to throw this party I said oh my
god I love it the party's amazing yes
the mayor is here in everything I said
but that's too much money as you come to
my place in LA I'll throw your party for
400 bucks
that will rival this party and he got a
little mad cuz you know he was like
y'all know I'm known for this [ __ ] don't
front I said I respect you I said but la
I just know how to get around so he gets
to LA and he calls me early in the
morning y'all play but make that [ __ ]
happen as a setter I said cool I'm going
on my phones and by 12 o'clock at my
small house in Tarzana and God bless my
neighbors that live there I'm no longer
there I know that he wanted me to get
out it was too much but the party's
fevered pitch and I invited the right
people you know the right girls were
beautiful but not too tight not too you
know just everything was great the guys
went no hater is there you know LA you
know me [ __ ] not wondering that it
was the right guys and he shows up and
when he shows up he goes that's the girl
on that TV show that's the girl in the
movie you're a friend he's like we're
all hanging out here so it's like you
know it's all good and that's the cookie
I said yeah yeah I said but look at the
party I said look over there on the
table
I got Kentucky Fried Chicken but I put
it in a nice plate I got coca-cola but
it's just in a picture I said we're at
280 bucks right now and Counting I won't
go over 400 and he had the most
incredible time right but at that party
was all musical people and I I did it
for a reason at that party Missy Elliott
of course she had her room everybody's
going crazy with Missy Elliott I'm going
to my garage and there's two guys a
little guy like this and on tall guy had
the little guy go she'll be you know
it's like this all the time be I said
yeah who you he said uh we didn't have
tunes
my name is Pharrell I said yeah I'm
gonna hurt you that's how long ago this
was wow so he's like can I just go and
have a great time there was another guy
standing on the wall green jacket like a
green little jumpsuit nobody's talking
to him guess who was who jay-z great
party
so hazy no one knows but and now the way
I got into the music however is that all
these different party was going on and I
would have liked different musical
people leaving me music in my little
studio that I built I went and got this
great studio built in them back in my
house and so one day in comes his kid
backpack on jaws busted who is it who
it's Kanye his jaws busted for my car
accident right Kanye and walks in and I
said who's that I said what I said new
[ __ ] Kanye may about to be the
[ __ ] I said what do you do well he
produces but he also raps I said well
anybody come to my house they gotta
perform
so I said yo man they say you you know
you rap [ __ ] he rapped the most
incredible free I don't know if it's
free so it wasn't her I said I don't
know why you aren't famous he did it
with a broken jaw he had a little
brittle jobs a little swollen I don't
think was broken but a little swollen
cuz it wasn't too long after that
accident that he had right and then he
goes uh I got a song dad you look you'll
be good on I got the song I know you
could kill I was like me song goofy face
[Laughter]
yeah [ __ ] cool
so we go in the back one my stats got
studio on the bed so he sings he says
the song is gonna go she said she want
some Marvin Gaye some Luther Vandross so
I said I got it she says she wants some
Marvin Gaye he's like what do you know
what I said well I got to put the you
know the arm be on it you know I'm
saying I'm a real singer you know I've
been singing he said don't do that just
sing the song cuz it's hip-hop and I
said ok cool so I but gradually sung the
song I'm thinking songs wack he's not
gonna make it so I went off I did a bad
movie I come back about six weeks eight
weeks later that song is number one my
boy goes like you remember that song you
said what [ __ ] is number one in the
country and then that's how I got into
the music so long story longer it's like
yeah you can do all of the things and
there's a lot of actors and actresses
that can you just need those
opportunities
like in life when you're when your
opportunity comes if you're prepared for
it now you could jump into it and grab
it and what I was told was by my god
Breann who does all of my music he found
slow jams he found gold that he found
blame it on the alcohol he says you got
to stop singing funny [ __ ] and seeing a
real record and once you sing the real
record and not say it's you singing it
now you got a better go so now after all
of those years the people that grew up
with me what doing stand-up or watch it
cutting date they're older and that a
young folks is like you to Kanye man
just like how you know the guys now
going to Michael John so so as I get
older you hope that you're blessed with
opportunities and you know so old Sam
butters sort of reinvent or reintroduce
yourself to people who may not know who
you are well it's also guys like you
have other interests you have more than
one interest you don't just want to be
funny yeah there's a lot going on in
there it's a lot you know but like like
we all are like comedians we got a lot
of [ __ ] that we want to get out and like
I said being a comedian we have we used
to have it's getting is getting crazier
it's getting tough on us as far as you
know everything we say you know they
want to come kill this right I mean I
did I did one I did Jimmy Fallon once
eating that Jimmy Fallon in every
organization want to get me what did you
say I was doing a joke I'm singing you
singing these funny songs about who let
the dogs out and so we took who let the
dogs out and put it in like a like that
like a vaudeville or a show tune who
left the dogs at whatever it was right
but beginning of that I sort of ad-lib
like I was watching these dogs in they
were coming towards me and I was
wondering you know who let them out and
there was a pitbull there and you know
you have to be careful because pitbulls
can be cantankerous you know and then I
go onto the song the pitbull community
it was like Jamie Foxx says pitbull
Seamus
and then there was another thing where
Jimmy Fallon was doing was doing some
type of uh he was saying what was gonna
be in the next show and I was doing a
bad version of signing which I actually
know how to sign I was doing a bad
version of sign language I know sign
look talking about it later you know all
those types of different thing but as I
was doing it as joke I didn't know that
the person that he was talking about
happen to be deaf oh no oh my god and so
then you know so just all these things
and I try to tell people I said hey
listen we never mean anything bad we
poke fun but we're not we don't mean
anything bad but you can just you know
we can't you can't kill us all right and
cuz I gotta keep doing what I do you
know so it's it's getting tougher well
it's just what we're talking about about
social media about people commenting on
things that you can't read the comments
there's just too many people yeah and
people are always looking for something
to be recreationally outraged at yeah in
the comments to get that ass through the
comment comment hit you right where you
are sometimes right well it's good to a
little bit it went there right when
they're actually right like someone can
say something ridiculous about you and
if you know it's ridiculous it doesn't
mean anything but if it's got a hint of
truth you like but when somebody says
something about your teeth you kind of
look in the mirror house damn [ __ ] I
guess somebody hit me with the donkey
then you know it's [ __ ] donkey so you
know but I tell people all the time
don't read the comments that's the book
don't your comments cuz it will make you
start to change the way you do things if
I read all of the comments I never tell
another joke yeah if I read all the
comments I'll never try another you know
I got a movie that we just shot for a
little of nothing called all-star
weekend and if the jokes are like all
the way out there you know and it's I
got everybody in it you know and we're
all taken we're all play different
characters like I play a white racist
white racist cop and how do you do that
oh I'll show it to you I'll grab
everything show to you but it's a Robert
Downey jr. plays in Mexican Gerard
Butler plays a Russian who loves
gymnastics
Benicio del Toro plays this crazy tattoo
artists and we're all you know we're all
doing our thing so it's like if you read
the comments that'll make you tuck that
in but this is some brilliant and it's
it's a cool little thing - it's called
all-star tweaking for a reason it's
about two guys one guy loves Steph Curry
the other guy loves LeBron James and all
they're trying to do is get to the
all-star game and it's sort of like this
whole journey of running all these
people so it's dope but it is some
things where it's like oh you know you
can see there's gonna be some some [ __ ]
going on well Robert Downey jr. just
from Tropic Thunder think about that you
could never do that anymore you can't
have blackface anymore yeah you know
what I'll say this people have to
understand where it comes from there are
real people out there that really mean
you harm like outside of us I mean
there's some real people who really
don't [ __ ] like you whatever you are
whether you're black you're white you're
straight you're gay whatever it is
there's some people who really don't
like with the entertainment and it's
easy we're easy targets
what easy it's easy for you to jump on
and Robert Downey jr. or Jaime 5 so Jo
because it's easy you know when it's
real things which you know whether it's
politics or whether it's whatever a lot
of times we we sort of we're not ready
for that fight but it's easy to sort of
pick the comedian I call Robert I said
listen I need you to play a Mexican he
says dude here's the deal sure why not
[ __ ] it sure of course yeah Mexican
whatever but then he text back and said
I'm nervous to play the Mexican I said
wolf [ __ ] you played the black dude and
you killed that [ __ ] we're just all you
know we got to be able to care what kind
of blowback did you get from playing the
black dude none because we fuss before
the wire too though it was like what
year was Tropic Thunder I feel like I
was like 10 years ago it was wild but
but here's the thing
we [ __ ] with Robert Downey jr. like
that's my guy right like I did his
birthday party and my first joke was how
dare you take all of these roles from
black people you know anyway everybody's
laughing so it's sort of like the
entertainer's man we should you got to
give us room you know I'm saying like to
play in it I'll show you when I got to
take that room you got take it you can't
worry about ourselves Chappelle's
was like you never asked him about his
jokes and he's like yo man look you know
people have said worth [ __ ] and I think
he said something about Donald Trump
saying grab by the [ __ ] or some [ __ ]
whatever but it was true it was like the
one thing that you look at what happened
with politics this year people sort of
stripped away a lot of things you know
saying regardless of what you believed
in whatever person you voted for there
was a lot of things that was sort of
addressed about like maybe we were
playing things a little too close like
some of those politicians were afraid to
say what Donald Trump was saying and
they ended up being left in the dust
because people a little like whoa what
he's got a point in the sense that we're
playing things a little too close so
when you look at that as a comedians
like wow you know that was that was good
for me and it was good for me in a
certain way of first of all it's great
jokes - it's like it does say are we
becoming too fragile when it comes to
our race like black folk like I say yeah
some people are racist and some people
are perception is know what that means
know the perception is okay the
perception in America was the white man
Donald Trump can be President the woman
can't do it perception doesn't mean that
if you vote for Ronald Donald Trump that
you're racist I don't think everybody
was that was a big thing sometimes it's
perception
I'll make I'll make it clear okay I do a
joke in front of all black people and I
said black people are very interesting
people because we deal with racism and
perception ISM I said because we're very
nervous flyers all right we don't like
to get home planes first thing we do
when we get on the plane we see who's
flying this [ __ ] we look in the
cockpit if we look and see a black guy
we will stop and go eh how long you been
flying you got your hours with you and
it was the perception and don't let a
woman sit next to him oh [ __ ] we good
uh-huh it could be a bright sunny day is
that how's the weather oh we're good and
then as you're sitting in that seat
anytime you hit a bump bump my breath
will be straight same situation you go
in in the cockpit you see that white guy
with that salt-and-pepper hair and those
aviators
and its form here like this in a storm
and I sat [ __ ] fly to [ __ ] through a
hurricane so it's the perception that we
have to talk about sometime
does that make sense oh it definitely
makes sense yeah you know there's
definitely that you know like the the
Donald Trump thinks funny know who had
it said it best Alonzo Bodden you know
Alonzo no I was a funny comedian yeah he
said he goes not all Donald Trump
supporters are racist but all racists
are Donald Trump supporters that he
definitely awaken that side but I will
but I will say this like I said the
perception gets us all - yeah you know
cuz like my daughter
it was interesting my oldest you know my
oldest daughter like when when when the
election happened and when you know the
results came in
y'all vote but you know I said well you
know you got to get out there because
their perception was she had it in the
bag right you know so you got to get out
there and be you know whatever that is
yeah whatever that is indeed this is
weird times for everybody you know
because I think social media is allowing
people to express themselves yeah
everybody's expressed themselves and
luring them forming groups you know
they're just like you know they're
progressive or they're they're they're
liberal or they're conservative and this
everybody has a voice is everybody has a
voice there's so much voices I'll say
this maybe you can appreciate this
because we've we've lived we're living
in tours we lived when it wasn't here
and it's its discretion social media
allows you not to have discretion you're
able to go in and type whatever you want
to say and that usually that's what we
pay attention to discretion is this
we're sitting at the dinner table and yo
I said something that you didn't like
but the discretion was I'll address that
later right so now that you don't have
any discretion anybody's voice can be
heard not everybody how do you say it
not everybody has a point
that
we should hook all of our wagons to
write what I notice is that we will hook
our wagons to the most extreme point and
that maybe only 2500 people like when my
homies with him and said maybe what they
say men about sons I said how many views
are to get eighty thousand views I says
eight million people in Philly alone why
are you just listening to those eighty
thousand people so you sort of have to
put balance in the way you sort of sift
through it does that make sense it
doesn't make sense
yeah well the way I try to pour it out
to people if you run into a room and
there's a hundred people in that room
what are the odds that one person is a
[ __ ] idiot
100% right yeah one person almost almost
every room of a random group of a
hundred people
yeah Italy and I'm being very very
polite one person that means probably a
few probably a few but let's go with one
one out of a hundred so that means
there's three million [ __ ] idiots in
this country right just straight idiots
right non fixable idiots yeah yeah so if
you're gonna repack you're opening
yourself up to that if you're gonna get
your opinion swayed by people who just
want to just want to see if they can
affect you you just want to see if they
can [ __ ] with you touch you just see
things change get you to change the way
you're dressing and it's what I'm like
that's why I don't like so I tell all of
my artists and all my friends don't
change don't read it because what
happens is everybody starts coloring
inside the lines and now nobody's
dangerous anymore
right cuz you remember back in the day
on Madonna dangerous right gotta come
out naked you know just dance into the
Grammys like it's all good
so what I hope will what I always say
just don't tuck your art in dartium for
the for the comments because we'll end
up not having anything not having
anything to celebrate that is that is
good like having something so but
somebody did a song that was dope or a
movie that was doable got outside the
box as opposed to what we love
celebrating which is the crazy [ __ ] yeah
well especially for comics yeah that's
because it's one per if you do a crazy
movie there's a lot of people involved
yeah if you're on stage you say
something [ __ ] up it's just you yeah
well I got I'm going back out so it's
about to happen I'm gonna be passing out
a whole bunch of gift baskets
I'm going back out and I you know like
how much time did you take off I've
never actually taken off cuz I still do
gigs like I got a gig tomorrow st. Louis
you know private gig whatever but but
it's just you know like I know like as a
comedian you got to live like I just
can't jump out there and just start
talking or writing jokes like I've lived
through some crazy [ __ ] so I got to go
out there and talk about that you know
had I not cuz the one thing I hate is
the one thing that's tough for comedian
is to become successful because we talk
from a [ __ ] is [ __ ] up point of view
and I gotta have a little anger and I
gotta have a little poke fun and if I
become that what if I become what I
poked fun at then I can't get it off
that's why at my house people come to my
house my daughter's ask me that's dead
why is this room not there's nothing in
it I said I don't want to complete the
house because it gives me a sense of
like I'm still trying to get on like I
don't everyone I don't put like all the
pictures nothing is like perfect in my
crib there's a curtain right now that's
torn open in my bedroom I just got to
leave it like that I keep my house a
little so that we call it the
dysfunctional mansion I'll talk about
that the dysfunctional mansion where
there's always somebody like like the
other night there's Odell Beckham in my
house battle dancing Chris Brown I just
just crazy [ __ ] happening at my house
all the time so I could I have something
to link my you know hitch my comedic
wagon to so you you create chaos on
purpose in a little bit of I just leave
it slight disarray I I don't I don't
remove myself from it I don't remove I
don't get behind the gates behind the
gazes of worship behind the gates behind
the gates when you get behind the gates
when you reach a certain point in your
behind the gates you can't really see
what I'm out I gotta be out with the
people I gotta have people like I had a
Abbey Tea Party right 3,000 people at my
house counted Jesus people at the gate
you know trying to get in is and as I
look through the party
there's Floyd Mayweather all-time yeah
you know such a box
I love you know got the fight coming so
there's Florida's Fat Joe this little
Kim is on stage performing and then I
look around and I see some of the home
he's like the real guys that was
sufficed I just a nice party right here
cuz I love it oh [ __ ] so it's all of
these mixtures of people that I can
still touch hang out with people from my
from my community
her name is unka she's like the
unofficial mayor in our city's a little
white lady from Germany and she's on the
dance floor dance with snow it's crazy
so I sort of keep it that way so I can
stay loose so when I go out I got I got
[ __ ] that I could talk about from the
hood to the way so you're still you
still managed to stay a regular person
got to but how that that's a hard thing
for someone who's achieved as much
success as you have that is not a easy
balancing act to stay normal because you
must get overwhelmed by requests and
people just wanting your time and wanted
a hitch hitch themselves to you and but
you got a look I think what helps me is
the failures like doing a couple of
movies that don't you know going through
TSA they don't speak to you your movie
is out come on through so or you just
get the TSA goddamn Fox what you're
doing baby what was that [ __ ] did last
year dog I had to watch that [ __ ] on
fire stick money so it's like you
appreciate those right uh which keeps
you regular keeps you humble and and you
just gotta sort of look at other people
and see how people in our business when
they do get behind the gates you know
you think comics that get that thousand
mile stare and yeah don't worry I don't
be funny no more yeah funny that's how
you came up I want to be sexy now you
know they they all fall into the sexy
I want to say funny and keep the teeth
goofy keep my head looking goofy hair
like whatever it is because that's what
I draw up on when I go out because
people can sense it
don't you think oh yeah yeah I think
stand-up is kind of in some ways it's a
like a mind-meld or a massive gnosis
like you're connecting with the audience
and if there's anything false about what
you're thinking or what you're saying
some of them at least can feel it yeah
sometimes all of them but some of them
can feel it and it'll [ __ ] with the
energy of the room but if you're in the
groove you're really being yourself
that's why when you see Dave on stage
one of the things about Japan is that
he's always himself yeah he can just be
himself and so you relaxed as an
audience member and slide right into his
mind and he takes you on a journey
cuz he's himself he's not he's not he's
not disconnected by Fame and celebrity
and that way he was genius how he passed
up all that money just went to Africa
yeah and just settled in and then came
back and didn't do any scheduled gigs
for years he would show up with a
speaker and set up a speaker in a park
in like Seattle and just gather a crowd
around and start doing stand-up him see
but that's what I'm saying it's like how
do you find that he figured it out he
did it well I agree with that because
like I said if you success can sometimes
be our our coffin especially when you're
like I said when you when your comic
even all the way down to the way I
handle like like like social medias
interesting like I mean you know and me
just sort of brand-new on it and what
people view like I was uh and this is
sort of something but I was uh just
talking about how people view you I went
to the gas station and I put on these
shades and then I took a picture unless
I was cool I was I needed some just pick
up some you know $14 [ __ ] whatever now
put it on I took a picture with him and
my Instagram blew up like oh [ __ ] what's
this I read the comments like man we get
to change that middle Ferragamo Gucci's
what autos down ain't let me get any
fire I was like wow he's just gas
station chase
but everybody thought they was you know
something else and I was like now I want
that I don't want them to think that I
don't want them to think that I spent
$2,000 on some [ __ ] cuz that's we always
lose I [ __ ] shades anyway right so I
actually hit my boy Dave oh and Dave
Schottenstein I said listen I want to do
i glass like what do you wanna do you
wanna I want to do an eyeglass that cost
less than $30 I said but what we're
gonna do is we're gonna go through each
frame and make sure each frame is tight
like the dope like amazing cuz I told
them the story about being at the gas
station and they were like wow I think
that's a good idea so we ended up doing
this whole line I went through all 200
frames and we did this lines it's called
a Prive revo right and everybody thought
that it was something else
30 bucks $30 shades and now even JLo
bella thorne and all these other people
are wearing the shades because what we
noticed when we did do that people
embrace it a little more because we did
a commercial that was that we almost
made a mistake where we get clothes on
and we tell people how much the clothes
cost and people got turned off because
the jeans were like $400 a jacket was
2,000 like what the [ __ ] and we only
know what we were trying to say was
although these clothes cost this our
glasses only cost 30 bucks so that story
in itself I take that and run with that
and say like I'm not the guy buying the
high-end you know right stuff I want to
keep it sort of cool regular you know
saying yeah does that make sense it does
yeah I know really rich dude who drives
a pickup truck
he's rich as [ __ ] and he just likes to
drive around in a shitty old Toyota
pickup truck he likes it and when I do
that cuz he wants to steal normal feel
normal grimy you want to feel normal
it doesn't wash its hands sometimes get
dirt under his fingernails pretends he's
a farmer and goodbye the whole [ __ ]
world but we had to balance both because
I because because you know you know
being me you know being
urban I got a step out there and shine
sometimes too I'm a boy has you know you
know we we get out there we show a
little bit of the success you know I'm
saying just to let people know we still
doing that thing I love the expression
being urban when we hear was that like
I'm black I'll tell you all time I'm an
ni CCH nikka if I lose if I lose being
that if I lose being that than I I gotta
have that oh yeah yeah no I got it you
gotta have everything yeah why not it's
fun too right yeah it's fun too but I
gotta I gotta have that part I gotta
have always had that sort of like a
ceilidh can't leave where I came from
right that's that's what they try to
snatch from me that's why we did we did
the television show Chris Spencer and a
buddy Lewis wrote this wrote this
incredible script called white famous
and white famous was about a comedian
who's you know trying to become
mainstream without losing is you know
his black audience which is all these
all of us we go through that right you
know because the minute you started
doing the you know the sort of soft
movies and you know I think the problem
with shining is when it defines you yeah
the problem when when you just
everything is flat like Floyd Mayweather
in a way it's part of his persona it's
part of why people root against him like
Boyd is a genius yeah my opinion not
just a genius boxing he's the greatest
defensive boxer my opinion of all time
but also a genius in that if you figured
out a way where he has this style that's
not appealing to a lot yeah but what is
appealing is people want to see him get
his ass yeah yeah and it never [ __ ]
house listen and you know Floyd's the
homie Floyd comes by the house man and I
don't want to put everything out there
that he does he's super super
competitive that's what's amazing but he
also understands that yeah Jay Fox I
understand what's going on you know all
time they they want me to follow fox but
that's what keeping competitive you know
all time
easy work like work please so he was sit
at my crib and speak for like hours
about
the business of trying to turn these
boxers minds on like yo get your money
you know I'm saying don't you know get
your money get your business get off and
then he talks about what you said he
says I know the reason that I fight
Oscar De La Hoya on Cinco de Mayo is
because they want to see the vo he he
carved out a niche of being the the the
the charismatic villain does that make
sense
yeah and he wasn't in the beginning he
wasn't in what again he was pretty boy
floyd mayweather and then he became
money Mayweather yeah but how do you
stay pretty boy what the [ __ ] don't know
I mean he might have been like Sugar
Shane Mosley or something you know but
not really cuz Shane had lost to a few
guys like what Floyd did better than
anybody is not get hit yeah yeah he's
been hit like six times
right right really hard like never is
him and Zab Judah yeah Zab Judah but his
defining fight was the Morales fight
when he fought Morales god bless was
amazing and he also said that that hit
the Sugar Shane hit him with he'll tell
you said I hid when Sugar Shane touched
him he said that really she said shook
nice about Jeff Fox about killing Jeff
Fox I gotta kill me he says that's why I
dug in you see the end of it you see the
end of the round and the end around he
did turn it but he's he got rocked in
that fight that was one of the few
moments where he really got caught
cleaned by a world-class fighter yeah
got caught clean twice so it'll be
interesting his next fight coming up
well Conor is not that level of boxer
you know someone I forget who it was it
said it I think it might have been his
day lawyer yeah but but if someone was
saying that he's got to I was Pat
Miletich saying that he has to almost
cheat within the rules I think he's got
to like fight in the clinch she's got to
like dirty boxing he's gotta be I got a
whole figure out a way to tie him up and
manipulate him and move his body around
he's got to figure out a way to be good
defensively too and he's got to hurt him
those are all like high high-risk
high-risk low-yield
possibilities what if it sees fight the
way I described it if you how would you
expect the greatest figure skater in the
world to do playing hockey against Wayne
Gretzky hi
it's not the same thing great freak show
ever this freak show ever I'm waiting
for that fight more than Canelo Alvarez
versus Gennady golovkin even though that
fight is a legitimate looking fight
because there's gonna be some crazy [ __ ]
some crazy [ __ ] these go be so crazy
well also there's the mindfuck factor
he's the Connors the only guy that
Floyd's ever fought that can look at him
and go if this was a real fight you'd be
[ __ ] dead oh no everybody else boy's
been able to [ __ ] up he [ __ ] up all of
them yeah you know like do you ever see
that video with him and Robert Guerrero
right before they fought they they had
this this thing where they were doing
photo shoots and they do a stare who's
this who's is robert the ghost guerrero
is a fighter that floyd fought maybe
four or five fighters ago right and he
just worked him 10 12 rounds [ __ ] up but
he's standing right in front of me you
ain't gonna do [ __ ] he's like you're
easy work you're easy work he goes he
goes I'm just and goes no one has to get
involved you're not gonna do [ __ ]
because we'll get right close to each
other you're not gonna do [ __ ] you're
easy work and you could see the dude was
just there oh no like he knew yeah he
knew the Floyd was right very well what
Connor looks at him and goes if this is
a real fight I'd [ __ ] kill you I'll
do your boxing thing it's a real fight
I'll kill you yeah oh yeah he's right
he's right yeah before he could say oh
the same we'll do some MMA he said it a
couple times next fight will do MMA he's
not doing it look for one thing for it
is he's smart yeah so he look he's got
him on his his is his playing field so
it's almost like you start to like I
know but people start to go like his
Floyd nervous I said I don't know but I
tell you it is he's definitely allowing
this guy to play through yeah and that
fight is becoming bigger Oh bigger oh
yeah bigger and bigger so it's like it's
gonna be he's gonna be great and the one
thing floor would always tell me though
he said Jay Fox he said one thing they
not ready for is the lights that's what
you mean he said the lights when the
lights are that bright and you look out
and you see all you see Denzel
you see all these that's a different
that's a different thing because if you
took I don't know if it was Hatton I
think what's on my hat is in the lights
man he said that's one thing I've been
fighting Jeff I have been fighting under
the licence always like this yeah so
it'll be interesting yeah it is gonna be
interesting crazy but Connor fights
under the lights too we just never boxed
anybody like that that's gonna be a
totally alien thing when he gets into
that ring he's got shoes on and he fills
those big-ass gloves on his hands and he
looks on the other side he sees Floyd
just moving around yeah he's got there's
gonna be a something in there it's gonna
be everything [ __ ] everything cuz you
think about it both I mean they got it
they got us I'm going I'm going early
press conferences were amazing yeah I'm
already booked I was booked in DC that
night in advance I so already sold out
to nut two shows that night I couldn't I
couldn't cancel and you can't cook no I
can't come I'm not gonna be there I'm
not gonna work it either they wanted me
to do something for it can't even do it
that's gonna be I gotta figure out a way
to not see it until I know what happened
there's no way watch it you know I'm
gonna have to figure out a way I hope
the audience would be nice and not
telling me there's probably gonna be
people watching it on their phone while
the show is going on no no like I
guarantee you like if someone gets nah
yeah what happens great yeah great man
it's gonna be interesting listen it's
amazing yeah I don't know that's what we
starting where do we go from here
we just keep moving keep moving you you
obviously enjoying yourself you're hi
I'm having I'm having a good time for a
super successful guy you seem completely
balanced today happy there there are
there are things that you just cannot
get away from that you you know you hide
right behind but and for the most part I
did some smart stuff moving off my whole
family lives with me so I had to worry
about you know my father my mom lived
with me oh that's great yeah and I was
adopted
seven months so me and my mom near my
biological mom you know are crafting our
relationship now in
in the latter stages of her life so you
know that's you know but I didn't want
but I didn't want no [ __ ] outside of
that you know where someone is is is
sitting somewhere watching me from a
distance like you know that you know
some mom comes in day and they've been
divorced for almost 30 years was crazy
why they live in the same saying under
the same roof is hilarious there's a
whole nother show Wow and he still dates
you know say he's still getting it in
over there and then she'll float over to
his side of the house be like see the
girl hey how are you who's this Wow
getting some I just want to get
something to refrigerate it some spoiled
stuff that's kind of intense and then
you hear that on my door I miss my papa
could you tell her not to come on myself
yeah I'm like my parents you know so but
it's certain things that I but you got
to figure out your happiness and the
only way you figure out your happiness
you got to try to see or foresee what's
gonna be the problem
so I get my family close to me so
whatever problem we got to work out we
work that [ __ ] out right here get my mom
and my my and my sisters and my
daughters close to me so they see daddy
going to work like this still some work
[ __ ] it's like nah we just not on the
red car it's not just red carpet every
day you know I got to get up I got to go
you know I got a talk [ __ ] I got a kiss
little ass here I got a I got to do a
whole lot of [ __ ] in order to keep this
thing going so you try to you know in
life you try to see what try to foresee
what's gonna happen it's still gonna be
something it's just always gonna be
something and just outlandish but uh you
try to get a get in front of it that's
an interesting way to handle it though
to bring everybody close to you bring
your whole family in your house yeah and
not everybody can do that you know
because you know it's like you know me
growing up as an only child I like
having people around I can't be by
myself that's why I always would throw
parties okay I would kidnap people
because I just wanted people right now
having my family around you you got to
do but not like I said not everybody can
do it because it you know it is
interesting like my father who has a
great story my stepfather has a great
story
you know he was on drugs or I had a
situation about with drug bout with
crack I ended up going to jail I wrote
him one letter I said you get out you
know I saved you life cuz I didn't like
writing letters to people and like going
visiting people in jail he gets out this
is around just before 9/11 and then my
stepfather was incredible in my life
because he taught me how to play tennis
so back in the 70s and then in the 80s
he was like playing tennis I'm like wow
I never seen a black dude play tennis
he says you gotta learn sunny so people
like Yannick Noah in Le nastasi beyond
Borg Vitas Gerulaitis those are like
heroes of mine so he taught me how to
play play tennis so when he gets out he
gets out of jail and make sure
everything is cool I take him to the US
Open and so there he is me my pops
watching Venus play he's crying
yeah this you know this is what this is
how we got to live this is what this is
what we need to do so he watches Venus
play in a couple days after that it was
911 but you know he stayed with me then
we mean since then you know early on I
would just go by check the drawers make
sure there's no paraphernalia you know
wrong [ __ ] smokey we cool right look at
don't do me no more than that and we've
been cool since then you know and it
saved a lot of money and we had young
Saiyans I'm just right there hands-on
but sometimes he was just being
surrounded by loved ones is enough to
keep them from doing anything stupid
yeah it can and it was but it was bumpy
at first weren't going to it because he
wrote a little book and talked about it
it was bumpy at first because when he
first got out I did some [ __ ] for him
got him this kind of got him car
whatever he relapsed his car gone he's
back in you know so it was a couple
little things that we had to work out
but now no to see him now like you know
you know like you know we go to these
different events or whatever like that
his whole wall he old school he own him
do this the you know this he got the
actual photos you go go develop the film
I got me a little film Dabangg so he put
the film in to develop the film see and
they put the film he got a whole wall
and everybody these met you know all of
his heroes and so like I said you know I
try to try to look try to be ahead of
the curve when it comes to the [ __ ] up
what about like what your creative time
when you have so many people living with
you and did you get do you ever feel
like boxed in no that's you know like I
know the best way to create is to have
people's around because I could try that
joke out on them and they don't know I'm
doing that joke you know try this idea
see how they respond cuz your family
gonna give you the real don't get mad
terrible yeah you made the answer you
always got it to me having people around
to tell you the truth you know like
everybody my family you know they tell
me is true for Vasu mmm that's sleepless
I should have just stayed sleep oh
really yeah so it's like you know having
that allows me to create and then I have
my own little space where I go okay let
me get this
now let me they responded to that and
now let me put this together over here
in a little space so you have like a
little sanctuary I got a little I got a
studio that's then I set up where I go
in there and do all that [ __ ] you know
but it helps well this is a man I know
you got to get the [ __ ] out of here you
only here for an hour right yeah but
it's been great dude listen you are
you're an amazing person and I'm very
I'm very honored to have you on here
because you're one of the very few
people that I know that has this
well-rounded life but also is very
balanced like you've had amazing success
and all these different things but
you're as normal and approachable as
anybody I know when I come to you you
know I got to be Y you because you are a
speaker of truth and we've seen each
other awhile but the one thing about
your opinion is always going to be
truthful so you know as us coming from a
different time there are certain people
that we want to have the real truth come
from you rock Chapelle all these guys so
we came up so when we're doing our art
or when we're doing whatever we do yes
always gonna be those people that you
know rock with you but you want to get
the people who have a really artistic
real opinion does that make sense yeah
no I know and if you hear them say you
are kind of [ __ ] with that okay
if jr. says that's cool then I know and
that's why you said it cuz that
[ __ ] tell you he'll tell you -
that shit's back you know saying and
then you hope your ass you know saying
so you got to be you know you got to be
on point with this because I know when I
run into those guys like you you want to
have that favor does that make sense
I know exact what you're saying you got
yourself to stay you got people in your
mind right now then when you're doing
your thing that you know if everybody's
yelling like oh we love you but if that
person say maybe there's so maybe that
you go okay yeah you're saying people
are gonna be a percent real yeah yeah so
yeah there you go
you're a bad [ __ ] Jamie Foxx
thank you brother you are - all right
all right they told me to say Prive
groove oh yes I'm calm preview
you lose your clothes you never lose
your glasses man and it's all I'm a
29.95 and there you go there you go
ladies and gentlemen he's
[Music]
[Applause]